so wie jetzt aber viele liebe grüße jury
die schweiz wir begrüßen euch heute aus
zürich in der schweiz und bei uns sind
claudia und nino ihr seid deutschlehrer
und wir sind diese woche eingeladen
worden von der hallo deutsch schule hier
in zürich und wir wollen euch heute mal
zeigen wie in zürich das
schweizerdeutsch gesprochen wird
deswegen gehen wir jetzt hier auf die
straße und ihr werdet gleich das
schweizerdeutsch und speziell den
zürcher dialekt hören
mit einer ganz einfachen frage nämlich
was hast du heute gefrühstückt mal sehen
wie viel er davon versteht los geht's
[Musik]
was an die hüter morgens zum bäcker zum
einige skeptiker das ist alles und
nichts masse
nein das ist sehr gesund
das leben ist und was er stocker 96
minute zuerst und das ist so normal
jeder darf und wann sie mal so bezos
gibt es morgen früh
das ist sehr gesund den 10
ok und nur das ganze blut ansätze zur
trinke einen kaffee trinken sie endlich
das sind jetzt auch die noch wenig
bradley warum die meisten menschen
morgen morgen gar nicht dass irgendwo so
zeta jones news lee ja man muss ich gar
nicht gedacht ok hat dass bestimmte
grund warum der kasse hat ich mache das
auch okay warum eine straffung neuer
statthalter petit amour er ich habe mir
zum zmorge an ihren köpfen kann nur
einen grund
ja das hat einen grund für mich als eine
spezielle diät ist warum lügt will ich
jetzt morgen ist aber du hast sicher
morgen kommt ja was dann
sie will nur rang
was hast du hin zum tor gekommen
valerie software ist auf die straße
immer so naja aber die machen wo man so
einen schlag ist was haben sie zum
morgen kaum begreifen und zu schaffen
sind irgendwie sind sie zu holen und so
mit honig und joghurt erdbeere oder
stent sehr gesund in der höhe sonst
morgens gar nicht gar nicht und thomas
stuker einkaufen und was ich das immer
noch so zum zmorge hast ja ja morgen
morgen am wochen einig dass außer hat
sehr störend ist also ist durch seine
auf der zwölf mal beseitigt aber vorerst
nur geträumt und durchschnitts- morgen
ja auch unter wirtschaftlich und
regelmäßig darum ist es einfach so wenn
erster kann kann es inzwischen gar nicht
ehrlich sei okay und warum hast du die
kasse will ich am morgen mit masse nicht
warum nicht unbegrenzt zeit eigentlich
wirklich
es gibt viel butter gipfeli ok und dann
bist du zu oder es gibt ja leider ist es
mir was hat sie denn wie jessica soja
lockt das andere zum trinken tee und
kaffee schwarz wie zucker mehl wasser
wasser wasser
ok und du meistens tee oder und was
trinkt tee oder kaffee
kmt cancún der un im geschäft einkaufen
geschäften und wie lange brauchen wir
ungefähr zum morgen also unter der woche
lang für das 6 uhr und do titel stand
oder so 20 minuten die längste zeit zum
zum zmorge lassen bevor ich jetzt minute
unter der woche zwei minuten und wie
lang man sich ungefähr zum morgen asse
wie morgen die und ein schweizer führen
und dann gottes dreiviertelstunde und am
wochenende ist es dann auch nicht darum
woche an der schmitt sieht und dann ist
dies ändern ist halt voran später
einfach und durch afrika was ist die
sturm wochen einen damals gleich oder
besonders was dazu und jetzt am
wochenende zum beispiel ist das gleiche
oder nimmst du die sich besonders durch
den man meistens limitiert und ist
meistens ezb oder joghurt die man
unterschiedlich und somit zum mittag
haben keine spaghetti unsere super
chance polonaise was sie selber machen
erzählt verständlich sein
bevor ihr jetzt in panik verfallen weil
ihr nicht so viel verstanden habt macht
euch keine sorgen ich habe auch nicht
viel verstanden obwohl schweizerdeutsch
hochdeutsch ist aber es ist eben ganz
anders als hochdeutsch
ja genau das ist richtig also es ist ein
dialekt und die leute sprechen dass auf
der straße untereinander
nichtsdestotrotz ist auch deutsch die
amtssprache die sprache die man in der
schule braucht bei der arbeit braucht
und deshalb lohnt es sich auf jeden fall
dass es gar ein muss dass man
hochdeutsch lernt wenn man natürlich
lebt das wäre meine nächste frage wenn
er jetzt in die schweiz kommt also
jemand kommt aus dem ausland in die
schweiz will hier arbeiten ja was soll
er dann lernen dass hochdeutsch oder den
dialekt ich würde sagen auf jeden fall
hochdeutsch weil das ist eigentlich die
basis ist auch die schriftsprache hier
bei uns oder was nino gesagt habe auch
die amt
sprache und wenn man dann dialekt zum
beispiel verstehen möchte oder später
sprechen ist das okay aber sicher zuerst
hochdeutsch und wenn dir das zum
beispiel hier in zürich machen wollt
dann könnt ihr euch mal die halo deutsch
schule angucken da unterrichten claudia
nienhoff recht habt ihr die beiden dann
demnächst als lehrer und die schule
verlinken wir hier unten und die hallo
deutschland auch einen youtube kanal
wir sind sozusagen youtube kollegen und
dort könnt ihr nämlich deutsch mit
dialogen lernen aber auch im buch
deutsch schaut euch das mal an und wenn
ihr lust habt übungen zu diesem video zu
bekommen dann könnt ihr auch ein
mitglied von easy german werden
das geht hier gibt durch die links unten
an danke fürs zu sehen
und danke dass ihr mitgemacht habt danke
und bis bald
[Musik]